So today I want to look at two kinds of
games and then more change topic of beds
and the game. Don't want to look at uh,
about ultimatums and bargaining.
I will start with ultimatums and we'll
move smoothly through and we'll see why
that's an easy transition in a while.
All right,
so the game we're gonna play
involves two players. Um,
let's do players,
whoops,
one and two.
And the game is this
player one is going to make
a take it or leave it offer,
take it or leave it
to play it too.
And this offer is going to concern a pie
and it's made the pie worth $1 for now.
All right, we'll put, we'll, we'll
probably play this for real in a bit.
We'll play it for $1. All
right, so it's a split of a pie.
We can think of the split as offering s
to play a one and one minus ass to play
out too.
Alright.
Asked to play a woman and one minus
asked to play two and play a two has two
choices.
Two can accept this offer.
Okay.
And there's two accepts the offer.
Then the shares are then the,
then they get exactly the offer play a
one gets asked and player two gets one
minus ass. All right? Alternatively,
play it to all play.
A two can reject.
And if play a two rejects the offer,
then both players get zero.
Both players get nothing.
All right? It's a very simple game.
There's a dollar on the table.
I'll take it out in the minutes
as dollar on the table. All right?
And our two players are
going to bargain for this,
but it isn't much of a
bargain plate player ones.
Basically you're gonna announce
what the division is going to be.
Two can either accept that division
or no one gets out of thing. Alright,
everyone understand the game.
So I thought we'd start off by playing
this game for real a couple of times. Um,
so when they come down and do that,
all
right,
so why don't we play with
them people in this role?
I've been playing with
that row all the time.
So a alley's going to help me find
somebody. You found somebody, okay.
So, uh, the person behind you
and your name is a Clia, Clia,
a shout out to build this. This, this
doesn't make a noise. Shack. Yeah.
[inaudible] Acquia. Thank
you. Acquia. And uh,
so you'll be player one and player two,
uh,
will be this gentleman here whose name
is, shout out Noah. Noah. Okay. So Queer.
Now do you know each other?
That's okay. Okay. So, uh, uh,
a queer can make any offer she wants.
We'll buy this for real money, right?
So there's a real dollar at stake.
You can make any offer you want.
It can be in fractions
of pennies if you like,
of the amount of dollar that
you're going to offer. Two. No, no.
The Noaa and the amount
you're going to keep yourself.
There you go.
Just shout it out so everyone can hear.
But he started standups enough.
So this is your moment in the rights.
The right.
Can you stand up as well?
Here we go.
You can offer him a penny and no. Are
you going to take a penny? No, no.
It's not going to take a penny. So I
didn't lose the money on that to no one.
No one made any money. I didn't lose
any money. That seems pretty good.
Let's try a different couple.
Let's move a movements mover.
Move around the room a little bit.
So, uh, why don't you, um, ally,
when you take the guy behind here whose
name is, shout out Gary. Gary. All right.
So Gary,
why don't you stand up and
we'll let Gary play with, uh,
the gentleman in here. What's the, what's
your name in here and niche. All right,
stand up and do you know each other?
All right. So what do we make?
What are we let a niche be player one
this time you understand the rules of the
game.
So make your offer 30 cents,
which is that you'll be like, oh, look
for him. I'll bring him 30 cents. No,
that's okay. He's saying he's saying
no as well. Okay. Okay. So, alright,
let's raise the stakes of it. Let's,
let's, let's make it $10. All right,
so I'm not getting much acceptance here.
Let me try a third capital. All right,
working my way back. So how about
you? What's your name? So when,
when you stand up as well.
Well at court and be player one.
And actually what I do want
to sit down so I can, I can,
I can do it from here and you and
you are Danny. Danny. All right.
The court is going to be player
one and Dan is going to be planted.
He's weren't on dating
couples from earlier. Right.
We're safe from that. Okay,
good. All right, so, so Courtney,
what are you going to offer?
$5 which is half of the $10
uh,
except all right. Except all
right. All right. All right.
So it turned out in this game that's
a lot of people are rejecting offers.
Let's have a look at it on the border.
Second,
think about it in a second and
we'll come back. We're not done.
We're not done with this couple.
I don't know any of your couples.
We're going to come back to
you. All right? So in this,
in this game it has a pretty,
it's pretty simple to analyze this
game by backward induction, right?
By backward induction. We're going to
start with the receiver of the offer.
And the receiver of the
offer is choosing between,
okay.
The offer means to them, which was,
which is an annotation is one minus ass.
And our three examples,
that was the penny than it was 30 cents.
And then it was half of it to quote at
50 cents to to be consistent. All right.
And we actually saw two
of those offers rejected,
but according to backward induction,
assuming that people are trying to
maximize their dollar payoffs here,
what should we see? The, what
should we see the receiver do?
Okay?
They should accept,
right?
They should accept even the somewhat
insulting offer of a penny that was made,
even that someone insulting offer
should be accepted, uh, by, uh, by Noah.
Right? So, no,
it didn't accept the offer of a penny
and it's come back over this and no,
he didn't accept the offer of a penny.
And, uh, uh, I forget who it was with,
but our second play,
I didn't accept an offer of 30 cents,
but we've just argued they
should have been accepted.
They should've been accepted.
In fact,
when Acquia made the offer
of of one penny to Noah,
I think she assumed that Noah
would accept it as this. Right.
Why do you think do and accepted?
Shout out?
Because I felt it'd be better
off with a penny done. Nothing.
It would be better for the penny
than nothing. All right. All right.
And then we saw an offer, the offer
came up about who was my second offer,
my second offer and what you offer a
bit more. What do you offer more? Um,
it felt dirty. Pretty Fair. Shares
a lot better than nothing. Right?
Thirties in front of enough thing
or they're not necessarily fair,
but it's still better than nothing at all.
Right.
And where was my rejector of the second
author who rejected the second offer?
Why did you reject 30 cents? It's just
a pride thing. It's a pride thing.
It's a pride thing. Alright. And pretty
soon we converged onto, or the 50 cents,
which notice is no where near backward
induction. It's nowhere near vaccination.
So the third offer, which is Courtney,
that right. Why do you offer, what was it?
Half of it? Because half is
better for me than half had been.
You've nothing and you've figured he's
gonna, he's gonna reject otherwise.
And in fact he didn't reject what didn't
you reject? Five is better than nothing.
Probably better than nothing but that.
But the five is better than nothing.
Argument would've argued against
making any rejection in this game.
Is that right? Right. So
here's the game went backward.
Induction is giving a
very clear prediction.
The clear prediction is first of all,
the second player will except
whatever's given to them,
and second,
given that the first player should
offer them essentially nothing,
offer them just a penny, right?
So backward induction predicts,
backward induction predicts that
the offer will be essentially,
I'd say 99 cents and 1 cents or even
or even knew virtually a dollar and
nothing. All right, but
in fact we don't get that.
We get a lot of rejection of these low
offers and often we get offers made much,
much higher in the visceral dizzy of half.
All right.
Now why? Why are we seeing a failure
of backward induction in this game?
I think this is a,
this is not as you guys,
it's a very reliable results in
experimental data. All right? So why,
why do we see so many people
in this ultimatum game?
Both offer more and more importantly,
reject last them a small amounts.
All right, let's talk about it. So,
so one person said it's a pride thing.
It's a prior thing. Uh, where was I?
This let's try the other airline here.
So, uh, what's the, what's the
smallest offer you would have accepted?
What's your name? Festival. Um, um,
listen the same too.
Right?
So there are some backward induction
players in the room. All right? All right.
Who, who would, who would
ever rejected a scent,
who would have projected 10 cents should
be going on when we could be going down
at least who did rejected 30th sentence?
Few people dropped from 37
not money actually. Alright.
How many of you would have
rejected 50 states? One person,
even with a projected 50
sentence, right? But, but
essentially know what, okay. Okay.
So what's,
what's happening here?
Why do people think people are rejecting
what is essentially money from my
pocket? Right? There's nothing going
on here. I'm just giving you money.
Why are they rejecting being given money?
Um,
like over all the stakes are really low.
So if you have any value on it's or like
pride when people said, you know, it's,
it's not worth a penny or
alright. Sense. All right, so
it may be pride going on here.
So certainly one thing is about pride.
It turns out that people do this
even in quite high stakes games.
But you're right, certainly that trade
off is going to start to bites. All right,
what else is going on? So I agree.
Pride is part of what's going on.
What else is going on here?
Let's try and get some conversation going.
It was somebody in here,
I can get the mic and shout out your name
and really shout Peter Gordon. Change.
It's cumbersome. Changes come and
smoke. You didn't want to change. Okay,
fair enough. Fair enough.
But if the stakes go up, that
would get rid of that. Yeah.
Um,
maybe people are tying their own outcomes
to the other players outcomes as well.
Right? So maybe people have
different pay offs. To me,
people that people are comparing that
pay off to the other person's pay off.
That certainly seems like a
plausible thing to be going on here.
You might feel less happy about getting
20 cents knowing the other person's
getting 80 cents for example.
You want to be trying to teach them a
lesson to get them to offer more, right?
You might be trying to send a sort
of moral standard here. All right,
so there's some notions of indignation
or even teaching people that they really
should offer people in the war. All
right. What else could be going on here?
Yeah.
If people know I'm not going
to accept less than 50 cents,
then they should give me 50 cents
by backward induction. Right? So,
so part of what's going on here, actually
this game was a one shot game, right?
We just play it once and we
could've played it. In fact,
they often do to play this,
this, this way in the lab.
You could have played it without anybody
knowing who the other player was.
All right,
but particularly in this setting where
everyone can see everyone else and even
in the lab where people
actually come see people,
but they might imagine that
the game is really repeated.
You could imagine people trying to
establish a reputation. Is that right?
So there's lots of these reasons are
sort of moral indignation reasons or
teaching a lesson reasons,
pride reasons.
There's also this basic reason that
people might be thinking this game is I
should play this game as I would a similar
situation in life where I might want
to be establishing reputation.
All right?
So there's a certain amount of
confusion going on in the game,
but there's also a certain amount of,
of a lot of things make sense.
And I noticed that once we've established
that people are going to reject small
offers in this game,
once we've established people that
are going to reject small offers,
it makes perfectly good sense to
offer a lot more than than nothing.
All right?
It's not that surprising that once we've
established the idea that people are
going to reject small offers,
you're going to see people making
offers that are reasonably large,
although not usually larger than 50 cents.
Why is 50 cents so focal
yet as 50 cents so focal?
No trick question. I'm just asking me
why do people think 50 cents or so focal?
What? I think it's typical that people
end up offering around 50 cents. Why?
It sounds fair, right? It seems fair.
There's some notion of fairness.
It's not clear, by the way, what ethical
principle is involved here, right?
It's not clear that if you're walking
along the streets and you happened to find
a dollar at your feeds,
that you should pick it up and anyone
else you happen to see at that moment you
should get 50 cents too, right? That's
essentially what the situation is.
Then you just chose Depaul.
This dollar that I just gave you,
it isn't clear that there's
any particularly great
moral claim to give it to
someone else, but I think people read
this as a situation about splitting,
splitting a cake cake in an environment
of of distributional justice.
They view it as a larger picture.
Is that right?
So it turns out that the
large literature on this,
there's a large experimental literature
on the ultimatum game and there's an
even larger literature on an even simpler
game in which I give people a dollar.
I say,
you can give whatever share you wanted
to the other person and they don't even
get a chance to accept or reject,
right? That's called the dictator game.
The dictator game,
literally,
you'll just simply given a dollar and
you can get whatever show you wanted.
The other person,
it turns out even in the dictator game,
people give quite a lot of money or
that suggest that there really is some
notion of fairness or some notion of
of distributional justice going on in
people's heads. Yet rightly
or wrongly. All right,
so one thing that should tell us
is even an extremely simple games,
extremely simple games.
We should be a little bit careful about
reading backward induction into what's
going to happen in the real world.
Part of this is because as I mentioned,
the very first day of the class,
people care about other things than just
the obvious payoffs and part of it is
about more complicated things like
reputation and solid. All right.
Having said that, let's nevertheless for
the, for the purpose of uptodate, uh,
act as if we are going to do backward
induction and let's embed this into a
slightly more complicated gate.
All right?
It's on the more complicated
game is as follows.
Okay.
All right, so we're going to have
a two period bargaining game,
two period bargaining
and this two pair of bargaining game at
the beginning of the game is exactly the
same as a dollar on the
table and play a one
makes an offer
to two. I might, once again,
we can call this off our ass and one
minus ass just the same as before and
justice before play a two
can accept the offer.
And if they the offer then
this is indeed what they get.
All right.
But now if two rejects,
which is twos other alternative,
if play a two rejects the offer,
then we flip the roles.
We play the game again,
but we flipped the roles. So
we go to stage two. All right.
This is everything we've said
happen up here is stage one.
Okay.
And down here we go to stage two.
I need to stage to play it
to gets to make an offer.
Yeah.
To one player two gets to make it
off at a one. And once again we can.
Cool. Last one, uh, we've been a
bit, but to be careful, let's put,
let's put one's hair just to indicate
where in the first round and uh,
to see how to indicate where
in the second. All right,
so you make it offers s two and one
minus s two s two s as to is the,
is the, is that that goes to play
a one and one minus s two is that,
is that that goes to play,
uh, uh, to, to, to guests.
We can offer an a player one and
now one can accept or reject.
If she accepts,
then she gets her share from here.
Offers accepted.
And if she rejects,
let me get nothing.
All right?
So this game is exactly the same
as playing the previous game,
except we flip roles,
but we're going to add one catch.
The catch is this in the first round,
the money on the table is a dollar.
All right?
But if we end up going into
the second round, I was,
the first offer is not accepted
and we go into the second round,
then part of the money is lost.
And in particular we'll
assume that the doe,
the money on the table is delta.
All right?
What you could think of Delta as
being just some number less than one.
All right, so you want a concrete
example. Think of this as being 90 cents.
All right? So the idea here is if you get
into the second round, time is passed,
it's costly and to money
in the second round, uh,
is I think that money in the
second round is being worth less,
or can I actually think of this cake
being eaten up? Some of it's thrown away.
So much wasted. All right, everyone
understand the game? All right?
This is very similar to the previous game,
but we've got this second stage
coming in and we've got discounting.
So this is the idea
of discounting.
How many of you have heard the
term discounting before? All right,
so you're probably a storied
enough finance cost or a
macro class where we think
about the being of value
of money as value of time.
That money today is worth
more than money tomorrow,
partly because you could put the money
today into the bank and it could earn
interest,
partly because you're simply impatient
to get that money and go and have lunch,
particularly on the day in which
the clocks changed. All right? Okay.
So let's try this game again and let's
just, let's just play it for real.
So let's come down again. Hi,
everyone. Missed out down the game.
Basically the same rules that with this
flipping around and with the possibility
that the cake may shrink.
Let's see what people have learned.
So who are our first pet? Our first
power Acquia. And who was that quiz?
And Noah. All right, so a, a Quia what? W
what are you going to offer your player?
One here. All right. But if
your offers rejected, no,
is going to get to make an offer to you.
All right,
so what are you going to offer this time?
45 99 uh,
so 45 cents. Yeah.
[inaudible] 46 46. Okay,
so he, he gets 46 if you
accepts the offer, is that
right? Yeah, 40 46 missteps.
The offer all makes sense that he's
accepted that. Okay. That was easy.
That was easy. So that, that
was so, so uh, queer got uh,
got 54 cents and a Noah got a 46 cents.
All right,
who was our second path? Go second pass.
So that was a, I've forgotten a niche.
Right. And uh, Gary and
Gary. All right, so a niche.
What are you going to have
this done? I'll lock it. 43 43.
You're going to push the envelope
a little bit. All right. All right.
Then we're gonna accept it
as well. Okay. So people are,
people are converging here. All right.
And what about our third off? Uh,
offer receiver was Courtney and
Danny and Danny is a Courtney 30,
30,
30 for him.
Uh,
I like sad. Oh, a three acceptances. All
right, let's find out something here.
So I was hoping to get into the
second round, so supposing Ah, okay,
so you accepted, that's fine. That's
fine. All right. We will, no, no, no,
no chicken sounds around the
room. All right. All right.
So, uh, is down here, right?
Yeah. So Daddy, have you rejected or
you accepted? But how do you accepted,
what would you have offered
in the second round?
Uh,
45. 45. All right.
45 and would you have accepted that
in the second round if you're 30,
30 to minutes after? Yes. Yeah.
So, okay, so you might've,
you might've been better at
turns out. All right. All right,
let's go back through the se,
the other rejection. So the,
is it the other acceptances who up
my second capital, you offered 43,
is that right? Right. And you
said yes to 43 is that right?
Have you rejected 43 what would
you have offered back in return?
43 43 the same thing back would,
would you were you accepted it and he
gets 47 he would've got 47 in that case.
You're just being accepted
that, okay. Okay. And uh,
queer went first and she
offered 45 to, no, I know I had,
in fact you rejected what
would you've offered back?
I would have also done 45 same thing
back and we would you would you have
accepted it? Yeah. Okay. So,
so we can see here that the decision to
accept or reject partly depends on what
you think the other side is going to
do in the second round. Is that right?
So here you are, you're making, if
you're even in the middle of this game,
if you're a player too,
you've received an offer right now,
these offers sounded crazy.
I mean 30 cents was the lowest
where I'm another sign crazy.
And you're trying to decide whether
you should accept or reject this offer.
And one you have in mind is what would
I offer if I reject and will that offer
the, I then offer in the next round be
accepted or rejected. Is that right?
All right.
And so if we just work backwards,
we can see what you should
offer in the first round.
Should be just enough to
make sure it's accepted.
Knowing that the person who's who's
receiving the offer and the first round is
going to think about the offer they're
going to make in the second round.
I'm going to think about whether you're
going to accept or reject in the second
round. Is that right? Right. So
that sound like a bit of a mouthful,
but that mouthful of reasoning is
exactly backward induction, right?
It's exactly backward induction as saying
to figure out what I should do in the
first round. I need to figure what
I should offer in the first round.
I needed to figure out where the player
two is going to accept or reject and to
figure out whether he or she
is going to accept rejects.
And I have to put myself in his or her
shoes and figure out what he or she would
offer if she did reject and what he
or she thinks I would do if I got that
second Matt, offer that right. Alright,
so let's try and analyze
this as if backward induction
was going to work here as
if we didn't have to worry about
things like pride here. All right,
so this is the game we're actually
playing. Let's keep that one
and actually analyze it on the board.
I want to walk us from a rotary mundane
game of take it or leave it offers to a
more complicated game in which there
can be several rounds of offers,
but we're going to go slow on.
We'll start this with two rent.
All right?
All right,
so first of all,
let's just look at the stage one game,
the stage one game and it's keeping
track what the offer is and what the
receiver. This is the opera
and this is the receiver.
All right?
Hello. In the one with stage
game, the game only has one stage.
Then we know from backward induction
what the results should be.
It isn't what we find in the in the lab.
It isn't what we find in the classroom,
but we don't,
we should get the offer should offer to
keep everything essentially or maybe 99
cents but it's called it
one and the receiver gets
nothing. All right? So again,
I'm approximating it a little bit
cause it could be 99 cents and a penny.
But who cares? This is call it a dollar
and nothing if it's a one stage game.
All right, so now let's consider
a two stage game. All right?
And the two stage game,
the person who's making the offer in
the first stage needs to look forward.
Anticipate what would happen if the off,
if,
if her offer was rejected by player too
and play a two went forward into the
second stage.
Is that right from the two stage game and
the first stage of the two stage game,
the person making the offer
wants to anticipate what
the receiver would offer in
the second round where the
receiver to reject our offer.
Okay.
But we can,
we can do that by backward induction.
We know that in the second round
if the receiver rejects the offer,
then the second round of the two
stage game is what? It's a one stage.
Okay. All right. And we've just argued
as this, this, we printed these,
these we believe in backward induction.
In that case play a two who has done,
the author will offer a dollar and
play a one who is now the receiver.
What accepted and yet,
okay.
All right,
so play a one in the first
round of the two stage game.
Wants to make an offer that
just enough to get player to,
to accept it. Now. All right.
So let's think about
this check if play a one
offers to something more than what?
More than what? Tomorrow play a
two can get a dollar. All right?
But that's a dollar tomorrow.
All right,
so a dollar tomorrow is worth how much
today if we're discounting it just worth
Delsa, right? It's just worth Delta.
So if player one offers play a
two more than Delta time is one,
which is what player too can get
tomorrow then too. We're like steps
and if play a woman offers to
less than Delta Times a dollar,
cause you can get a dollar tomorrow,
but that's only worth delta. Uh,
that dollar tomorrow is
worth just Delta today,
then two will reject.
All right?
So the offer has to be exactly
enough to get accepted,
which is exactly Delta dollars. All
right? Delta dollars. All right?
So play a two knows that she can get
it in pink player to know she can get a
dollar tomorrow.
So you need to offer her at least
Delsa today to make it as good for her.
I was getting a dollar tomorrow.
All right. Do we know the receiver?
Must be offered at least Delta tomorrow,
which means the offer.
Okay.
It's going to keep one minus delta.
All right,
so this in the stay in the first
round of the two stage game
play a one should offer,
one might add one minus Delta took
for herself and Delta for player too,
and play a two shoot.
Except that because Delta
dollars today is as good as $1
tomorrow.
All right.
Or another way to see that isn't a
picture. Let's just draw a picture.
Okay.
All right.
Let's put the pay off of player one
here and the payoff of player to on this
access. All right, and
these are good. We'll get,
we're going to assume that it's going to
maximize dollars where there's no pride
in here and if we just
look at the one stage game,
we're simply looking at this line.
Yeah.
All right.
The offers and the one stage game,
it could be that player
one gets everything herself
and gives nothing to play a
two. It could be that player
to keeps everything fresh.
Again ended up getting everything and
play a one gets nothing and it could be
any combination in between. Right?
And we argued by backward induction,
although not in reality, in
backward induction in the real, uh,
in back conduction in the one
stage game play on one, uh,
makes an offer to play a two,
which is kind of an insulting Golfer.
Play one says I get everything
and you get a petty,
I don't know if this
is the one stage gate,
okay?
In the two stage game,
instead of it's in the Tuesdays gaming,
if things are settled in the first stage,
this line represents the
possible divisions between
player one and player two.
But if we end up going into the
second stage, the pious shrunk.
The pious shrunk instead of
being so going from one to one,
it goes from Delta One, two, Delta,
one off. It's like if Delta's 0.9,
it goes from 0.9 2.9. So let's draw
that line in. That's what we get into.
The second stage will end up being here.
All right?
How this goes from Delta
dollars here to Delta dollars.
There were these dollars,
those dollars are being evaluated at time.
At at time one hunter,
the pious shrunk.
If we get into the second stage,
then by backward induction play a two nos.
Pay a two isn't an ultimatum game.
Pay a two.
We'll be making the offer and play
a souk stays. Whatever cake is left,
I'm going to take all of it and
you're just going to get a pen.
So if we get into the second stage,
then play two will make this offer
to play a one.
I have to, we'll say I'm going to
keep, I'm going to keep all of that.
The whole of the pie, which in time,
time was in the in first period,
dollars is worth Delta.
So I'm going to get,
I'm going to end up with a payoff of
Delta and you're going to end up with a
powerful essentially nothing.
Alright, play a two nos.
Play a two knows that they can therefore
get at least Delta dollars or Delta
Delta and in current day dollars worth
from state, from rejecting your offer,
since they can get at least Delane
these Delta current day offers from your
offer,
the lowest offer you can make to them
isn't offer that gives
them at least delta.
So the offer you're going
to make is this offer.
This is the two stage offer.
It happens in the first stage,
play a one gives it,
makes an offer that gives player to
what play a two could get in the second
round of gives play a to Delta and
keeps one minus Delta for herself.
All right,
everyone was on the picture.
So this picture is just
corresponding to this table, right?
The thing people tend to get confused
about here I think is they get confused
between current dollars and uh,
and discounted dollars.
So we're going to do all the
analysis here in terms of uh,
the first period dollars dollars
tomorrow are going to be worth goals.
There's a hand up. Can I, can I
get a shout shouting out? Yeah.
Yes, yes. Sorry. Let me to
put those labels bigger. Yes.
So this is the outcome.
If it was a one stage game
and this is the outcome,
if it was a
a two stage game, right? The offer
is made and accepted. All right,
let's roll it forward.
Let's look at a three stage game.
Let's keep this picture handy
and think about a three stage game.
So the first beginning of the
game is the same. All right?
We're going to get three stage bargaining.
Okay.
And the rules in three states bargaining,
I pretty much the same as in two stage
bargaining but now there's two possible
flips in three stage bargaining.
Okay.
And three stage pocketing in the first
period and period one one makes the offer
and if it's accepted the game's over.
Alright,
in period two.
So if we rejects,
if project,
then we go to period to
when to makes the Alpha
and if it's rejected now
the signed by player one,
then we go to Paris three.
Well once again,
one makes the Alpha so you
can see where we're heading.
We're heading towards an alternate,
an alternate offer bargaining model.
I'm going to make an offer, Jake
Scott, either accept or reject that I,
he'll make an offer and we'll flip
to and fro. There's a question.
Let me try and get a
mic out to the question.
Yeah, yeah. Question about
the two player game. If
that's a shout out to be looking at here
is if Delta is the best that player to
can get tomorrow,
then why wouldn't you want one offer
player to Delta discounted by Delta today?
Right. So good. So I think I was confusing
about it. Somebody behind me clear.
So tomorrow play a two can get everything.
Everything that there is.
All right, so whenever whatever Pi is left
tomorrow, play a two can get all of it.
All right,
so call that pie tomorrow
one and evaluated in current
in in period $1 as being
worth delta. All right. All right.
Does that make sense? Okay. So I,
I think I misspoke on that. So let
me say it again. All right. So,
so every period there's this
pie. All right. And every period,
if it was the last period of the game,
the person making the offer is going
to get the whole pie. All right?
But if I view that pie
tomorrow from today, right?
A Pie of $1 tomorrow is only
worth Delta dials today.
A Pi of $1 the day after tomorrow is only
worth Delta dollars tomorrow and Delta
squared dollars today. And so
all right, so that, that, that's,
that's the way which we're going
to do discounting here. Good.
All right. All right, so this
game, if one makes an offer,
if it's accepted, it's
over, it's accepted,
then we're done. And if there's
offers accepted, then we're done.
And if this office,
except in the Madonna and the third round,
if it's rejected,
then both players get nothing.
All right? And once again,
we're going to assume,
we're going to assume that the players
are discounting. So what does it mean?
What does it mean to say that discounting?
It means that the dollars in
period one are worth dollars.
Dollars in period two RJ are discounted
by del Sur and dollars in period three
are discounted by Delta Times.
Delta or if you like by this question.
Yeah.
All right, and just to put this into
real, into real notions of money.
If you think of Delta as being 90% then
a dollar in period one is worth a dollar
a dollar in period two viewed from period
one is worth 90 cents and a dollar in
period three viewed from
period one is worth 81 cents.
All right?
Okay, so what do we think's going
to happen here? Wow. Once again,
we can do backward induction.
Here we are in our picture.
Let's look at the three stage game
and once again, when we analyze,
as always when we analyze these
games using backward induction,
we want to start at the end.
If we start at the end,
we know that the last stage that to
the third stage of the three stage game
looks like what it looks like,
the one stage game and in the one
stage game we know the offeror.
We'll get everything. All right, so again,
so the last stage of the three stage game,
we know the person who makes the offer,
who this time we'll be player one will
get everything however that everything is
only worth Delta in two n's in period
$2 and it's only worth Delta squared in
period one off impaired $1 all right,
so in period in period one it's
right in the first part of this game.
We know that if the offer is rejected,
we know what's going to happen.
Is that again, in the first
period of this three stage game,
if the offer is rejected,
then we'll go into a two stage game.
All right?
We'll go to a two stage game and we
already know what happens on a two stage
game and a two stage game.
The person who gets to make an offer
gets one minus Delta and the person who
receives the offer gets delta.
All right?
So we know in the first stage of the game
that the person who receives the offer
always has the outside option of saying,
no,
I reject and we know that that person
tomorrow we'll get one minus delta,
but one minus Delta tomorrow
is worth how much today?
Yeah,
it's Dell. So one minus it
tomorrow they're going to
get one minus Delta dollars.
So today that's worth Delta
one minus Delta donors.
All right,
so the offer I have to make in the
first round to make sure that the other
person except it has to be just better
in discounted dollars than what they're
going to get tomorrow. They're going
to get one minus Delta tomorrow,
so I have to give them Delta y
minus Delta today. All right.
Which means I keep for
myself one minus Delta,
one minus Delta,
and if you don't like the Algebra,
let's look at the picture and the
picture in the one stage game.
This is the offer in the two stage game.
We know if we get into the second
round play a two gets everything right.
We have to give him that much today.
And if we get into the third round,
now we're looking at
Delta squared here and Delta squared here.
I'll just go ahead and Dallas. Glad we
know that if we get into the third round,
the person who makes the offer and the
third round we'll get to to get, uh,
get everything so we can actually
walk away a lot of it. All right,
so in the third round, the
person who makes the third
offer, we'll get everything.
So in the second round,
you'd have to give them that much.
So I ended up first round, you'd have
to give plan to that much. All right.
Say that again.
In Paris three the person making
the offer can get, get everything.
All right? So in period two, they
must be getting a Delta Times that.
So in period one you have to give them
at least this much higher than this.
Here is
the offer you'd make
in the three stage guy.
All right,
so on the picture, it's just going and
doing a little zigzag on the, uh, on the,
on the, uh, chart. We're also
always working across the diagonal.
All right, so we've done the, we've done
the one stage game, the one stage game,
the person making the offer get to
everything in the two stage game.
The person making the
offer off as just too much,
just enough to get the offer accepted,
which is Delta because that's what,
that's what the dollar's worth
tomorrow in the three stage game,
the person making the offer makes
just enough to get the offer accepted,
which is del Sur times what the
receiver would get tomorrow.
What they get tomorrow is one minus Delta,
so they get Delta woman is Delta today.
All right. How about the forestage game?
It's, see we can do that. So we
go to the fourth stage game now
and the forestage game,
if the person receiving the
offer rejects the offer,
then tomorrow they can get one minus Dell,
so one minus delta.
So I need to offer them enough now
in current dollars so that, so they,
so they will prefer that to getting one
minus Delta one minus Delta tomorrow.
So how much we'll start off of them.
I have to offer them at
least Delta Times that much.
So I have to offer them Delsa times one
minus Delta Times one minus downside
like this. All right? And
again, I have to keep the rest.
I'll keep the rest of myself,
so I'll get one minus DELSA,
one minus delta,
one minus downside.
All right?
Actually the principal is always give
people just enough today so they'll accept
the offer and just enough today is
whatever they'd get tomorrow discounted by
Delta.
Right?
So actually this backward
induction isn't so bad. All right?
What makes it a little bit
easier is you don't actually,
what do when you go through
an extra stage of this,
you don't actually have to go
all the way to the beginning.
You can actually start where you were
last time and just discount once more by
Delta.
All right,
let's see. We can see it.
Any kind of pattern emerging
in this Algebra. All right,
so let's just multiply out these
brackets in the F in the forestage game.
This thing is actually equal
soon as multiplying through.
It's one minus Delta Plus Delta squared,
uh,
minus Delta cubed.
I hope it is. Anyway. That's what this is.
And this thing is equal to delta.
Delta minus squares
a plus Delta.
Cute.
Alright. Just multiplying
out the brackets. All right.
Does anyone see a pattern
emerging here and these offers?
We had offers of one and
then one minus delta.
So we can also multiply out this one.
It might be helpful to do so.
This is actually one minus Delta plus uh,
this is one minus Delta
Plus Delta squared.
All right?
They want to see a pattern.
What these offers look like.
They kind of alternate,
right? So let's, let's uh,
that's how I look.
What the,
rather than do every stage,
try it.
One more stages.
Here we can see a pattern emerging and
I just jumped straight to 10 stages and
see what happens. Go straight to
10. Then you'll say, let's do one.
Let's do one.
Just jumps into 10 to imagine.
But this game actually had 10 rounds.
This is the 10 stage game.
Let's just take this as,
continue our chart down here.
So here's a little bit more space.
Yeah,
right.
Tanner stages
10 stage game.
I'm going to continue my chart.
My chart says in the 10 stage game,
what am I going to get to the offer?
The offer is going to be easy.
The same pattern,
one minus DELSA plus Delta
squared minus Delta Cubes.
Don't Dr a plus Delta to the
eight minus Delta the night.
I want to see that what I'm
doing is I'm speaking, uh,
continuing the pattern from above.
All right, so I have 10 stages.
I always start with a one.
The positive and negative terms just
alternates and I have as many terms as one
minus the stage.
I entering the four stage game.
I ended up at Delta cubed
during the 10 stage game.
I'll end up at Delta to the line.
All right, now we're happy with that.
All right, so the fourth stage
offer is this slightly ugly thing,
one minus Delta Plus Delta
squared minus Delta cubed.
Dr. All right, so plus down
to the four minus up to the
five, et Cetera, et Cetera,
plus Delta eight minus Delta nine.
Right? That's a pretty ugly thing.
But fortunately some point in high
school you learned how to sum that thing.
Do you know what this is? What do you
call objects like this in high school?
I don't remember. And I remember
objects like one Delta, Delta Square,
Delta, Cube Dunk, the
Florida, what are they called?
They called geometric series right there
called geometric series and I remember
had a sum them,
we know that x is equal to this.
All right? This is what the
offer is. If there's 10 rounds,
we know the offers accepted.
All right? The way,
the way that remember how to stomach
it is to the trick for something.
It is to multiply both sides of this
equation by by the Cuban ratio to multiply
both sides by Delta.
Okay?
So if I multiply this side by Delta,
I got them off on the other side by
Delta on this one will become a delta.
This Delson,
this Delsa will become a delta squared.
This delta squared.
Okay,
we'll become a delta cubed.
This Delta cubed will become the delta.
The fourth don't, don't, don't.
There'll be a minus delta to the
age coming from the seventh time.
There'll be a plus Delta to the nine and
with the delta aids term and there'll
be a minus.
Okay.
Delta to the temp, right?
Everyone okay with that?
I just multiplied everything through
Phi Delta. I just shifted it along.
One for convenience. What
do I do now? Do you remember
I the two lines together. Let's add
the two lions together. All right,
so I something on this side,
I get one plus Delsa
that's 10
right on the other side. What's kind
of convenient is everything cancels.
The one comes through. I get a
one, but these two terms council,
these two terms council and these two
turn councils and so on and so on.
All the way out to the end.
Or I get minus Dal of the 10.
Okay.
We're okay. Well, the other types of
cancel out. All right, so now just uh,
sorting out my Algebra Brett,
I'm going to take on another side.
I'm going to have that.
They offer you make off.
This is what you're gonna get to
keep. So they might, they might not.
They might claim I should
keep in the first round is
one minus Delta to the 10
over
one plus downside.
I have a little bit careful up notation
here because maybe it'll a bit confusing.
The 10 here doesn't
mean to the 10th power,
it's just the offer in the 10th round.
Where's the tent here really
does mean in the 10th power.
Okay.
All right,
so if you play this game for 10 rounds,
the offer you'd make would be one minus
Delta to the 10 over one plus Delta,
which means that the amount of
your offering to the other side,
which is one ass would
be Delta Plus Delta,
the tenant
over one bus Dells.
All right,
so let's just summarize where we are.
We started off by considering
a very simple game,
a one stage take it or leave it offer.
We know that in that take it or leave
it offer player one is going to claim
everything for herself and
offer nothing to play at two.
Then we can see a two stage game which
was the same as the one stage game except
that if player to rejects the
offer he is go back to he.
He gets to make an offer to play
out one in the second period.
We know that in the second period
of that two stage game play,
it too can keep everything for himself.
Everything for himself tomorrow is worth
Delta today so you have to offer him at
least Delta today and keep
one minus Delta for yourself.
Then we noted a three stage
game in this three stage game.
If player two rejects
from the first round play,
a two can make you an offer on the second
round but now if your player one and
you reject on the second round you get
to make an offer to play or two in the
third round. We argued that in
the second round of this game,
the person if play a two rejects you in
the first round and makes an offer in
the second round,
it'll be at a two stage game and they'll
be able to keep one minus delta of the
Pie for themselves.
So you have to offer them at least Delta
Times one minus Delta today for them to
accept the offer,
keeping the rest of the ourself.
Then we look to the forestage
game in the fourth stage game.
If you play a two rejects your offer,
he can make you an offer,
but if you can recollect now
and you can make him an offer,
but if he rejects it off,
he can make you an offer.
And once again we asked how much do I
have to offer play a two now for him to
accept the offer.
Now he knows that if he rejects the offer,
he can get this amount one minus
Delta Times one minus Delsa tomorrow.
So I have to offer him del Sur Times
that today I want to get lucky.
I just saved myself.
All right.
That's just a summary of what we did.
And then what we did was we cheated.
We jumped to the 10th stage just noticing
that the pattern that emerged and we
found that the 10th stage,
this is the offer you'd make just
according to the same pattern,
and it was this horrible thing.
And then we used a little bit of high
school math to simplify this thing and it
turns out this is the amount you'll keep
yourself and this is the offer you'll
make to play it.
Let's see. All right. Each case, they'll
be accepted. I make a math mistake.
Thank you guys. Let's make, let's
put a Steven Strip to here. Good.
All right,
so what do,
what do we observe here?
So the first thing to observe
is in the one stage game, if we,
if we believe backward induction,
you certainly want to be the person
making me off in the one stage,
gave him the ultimatum game.
There's no huge first mover advantage.
Yeah.
In the two stage game, it's not
clear if you want to make the offer.
It depends on how large Delta is.
But if delta has a big number like 0.9
you'd rather be the person receiving the
offer
in the three stage game it looks like
it looks like you'd probably rather make
the offer,
but it's not so clear.
So where does it go to as we go down
the path as it goes down towards the 10
stage game,
it looks like in the 10 stage
game he was like a 10 stage game.
You probably still prefer
to make the offer the note,
but they're certainly much closer
together than they were before.
Some of that initial bargaining power
has been washed out by the fact that 10
stages.
All right,
so let's try and push this just
a little bit harder. What is,
instead of looking at the 10 stage offer,
what have we look at the infant
stage office? So what is the,
what is it in principle,
in principle,
we look at the infant stage of this game.
All right?
So I can make you an offer.
You can say no and make me an offer and
then I can reject to make you an offer.
And then you can object to make me an
offer and so on and so forth. All right,
so we look at this term.
If there's an in principle,
you could make an infinite
number of office. All right,
so what's this tone I'm going to look
like if I can make an infinite number of
office.
So I claim it's going to look like this
one minus Delta to the infancy over one
plus delta. And over here is this
it converge towards less than me.
Picked up more formal and over here we'll
have delta plus Delta to the infancy
over
one plus thousand
yeah.
However, now I can get, now
I get a little bit simpler.
What is Delta to the
infinity? It's zero, right?
2.9 times 0.9 10 point 909 has what?
9.9 0.99 a pound.
Mine is zero.
So this last term disappears.
Past does this one and we just
get one over one plus Delta
and
Delta over one plus Delta.
So if we,
like if we make alternating
offer bargaining bargaining game,
when each round I make you an offer,
you can accept it or you can reject and
make me an offer and we imagined this no
bound to this game.
It just goes on arbitrarily long.
Then our prediction is that player one,
the person who makes the first offer,
we'll get one over one plus Delta
of the initial Pi and play a two.
We'll get delta over one
plus Delta of the initial Pi.
Let's try and get a handle about
what those numbers are. All right,
so if you imagine these offers
can be made fairly rapidly.
For example,
I could make an offer today.
You can make an offer back to me and half
an hour's time and then I can make an
offer back to you in half an hour's time.
Then it's reasonable to assume that the
pie is not shrinking very fast, right?
The discount factor is not
a big deal here. All right,
so he's offers to be
made in rapid succession.
Then we might think that Delta
itself is approximately one.
The Pie isn't drinking very fast.
If Dell does approximately one right?
If we take Delta to one here,
that'd be the time.
Isn't that valuable given how rapidly
we can make offers to and fro.
Then what does this make this equal
and the case went delta is equal to one.
What did we get?
We got a health
which means this will also be
so we learned something from this
which is kind of surprising if you do
alternating offers this, that standard,
very natural game of bargaining,
sort of the kind of bargaining you might
do in the business and a market or the
kind of bargaining you might imagine
going on in negotiations between baseball
players or their agents and teams. All
general managers of teams. All right,
which offers just go to and fro and
they go to and fro fairly rapidly and in
principle they could make lots and lots
of office in principle what we should,
what this model tells us is in principle
we're going to end up with each people
with each side splitting whatever.
The Pie was
equally
very,
very different from the ultimatum game
where all the bargaining power was on the
person who made the first offer.
All right. All right, so
what are the lessons here?
What can we conclude from this?
We've looked at alternating
offer
bargaining
and we've concluded under under special
conditions we've concluded that you get
an even split.
Okay,
why didn't you get an even share and even
split 50 50 splits if three things are
true,
the first thing is there,
there's potentially infinite many offers,
potentially
potentially 10 bargain forever
if discounting is not a big deal.
What does discounting really
not being a big deal means?
Means there's offers can be made
in rapid succession. All right,
so no discounting.
Yeah.
Is there just kind of take it
or if you like rapid offers,
if you don't have to wait
a year between every offer,
that discount factor would be a big deal,
but I actually made a third assumption
and I made it without telling you what
was the third assumption I made.
I snuck a third assumption past you
without telling you what was that third
assumption?
Can we get that?
The mic? Can I claim I
snuck a third assumption?
There's somebody, let me start over
here. What was the third or something?
I don't know if this was really poor,
but they know how big the pie is.
They know how big the pie. That's true.
That's a big deal actually. It's true.
But there's something else going on
here. What else is going on here? Uh,
we assume that both players are rational.
We assume that that's true,
but we missed. That's, we've kind
of been assuming that throughout.
Back in induction.
You're right.
None of this packet induction would
apply so cleanly if we didn't just see in
that. What else do I say? It's hidden.
Actually I snuck it in.
A discount factor is a constant.
We are still just go have just a constant.
That's true, but not just constant,
but something else. You're on the
right lines. They're the same, right?
I've assumed here implicitly I've
assumed that both people are equally in
patient.
They have the same discount factor,
the same discount factor.
Delta one equals Delta suit.
All right.
Why does that matter? What does that
think about it intuitively a second.
Suppose that one of these players is very,
very impatient.
They need the money. Now. If
it's cake, they need the cake.
Now that very impatient and the
other person is very patient,
right? They can wait forever to get
this bug and to come across. All right.
Who Do you think's going to do better?
The patient plan or the inpatient player,
the patient is going to do better.
I had the patient placement to do better.
The way we ended up way we did all
this analysis is we assumed that those
discount factors were the same.
We assumed that each person was
discounting time at the same rate,
perhaps because they were facing the
same bank with the same interest rate,
but in practice,
often one side is going to be in a
hurry to get the dispute resolved on the
other side can sit around
forever, right? And in that world,
the side you can sit around forever
is going to do much better. Alright,
now we're going to look at relaxing
this assumption and this assumption in
particular,
we're going to relax it
on a homework exercise.
All right,
so I knew a homework exercise.
You're going to try redoing
part of this analysis.
Good practice anyway,
but doing it in a setting where the
where the discount factors are different.
All right,
so one thing we learned here was yes,
you get an even split, but it depends.
It depends on these three assumptions.
All right,
and it's kind of important because when
you, when you think about bargaining,
I think a lot of people simply
assume intuitively that will,
whenever the bargain is about,
people will eventually split on the metal.
When you're bargaining about a house
and what price you're going to pay for a
house,
all these things,
you kind of implicitly have
this assumption they're
going to end up splitting
the difference.
What I'm arguing here is you will
split the difference and this natural
bargaining game,
but only under very special assumptions
and in particular the assumption of
patients
for sure.
All right?
All right.
There's another remarkable thing
here though. It's also hidden.
So not only did we end
up with an even splits,
but something else remarkable
happened in this bargaining game.
What was the other thing?
Somewhat amazingly,
very unrealistic thing that occurred
in this bargaining game. Let's see.
We can spot it.
So one thing was an assumption I made
and the other is actually a prediction.
Yeah. So the first offer will be the
offer that's accepted. Good, good.
Everyone see that?
So in this bargaining game,
I set it up as alternating
offer bargaining.
So the image you had in
your mind was of haggling.
I made an offer. You guys thought about
this offer, shall I take this off? Oh man,
maybe I won't take this off and you make
me an offer back to me and we kind of
handles to and fro. But actually
in the equilibrium of the game,
none of that happened.
That will happen in our mind.
We thought about what offer we would
make and we thought about what offer you
would make back to me if I made you this
offer and you were drafted it and so on.
We did this backward induction exercise,
but it was all in our heads,
right in this, in this game.
The actual prediction is
the very first offer
is accepted. Very first offer is
accepted. There's no haggling,
there's no bargaining.
All right?
But that doesn't seem very realistic.
There's no haggling.
Backward induction suggests that
we should never see bargaining,
but let me see what the
actual process of pocketing.
Well we should see is an offer
is made and it's accepted.
Now what is it about the real world
that allows for haggling to take place?
If this was the,
if there was a model of the real world
and we will leave it backward, induction,
then we're done.
So why is it in fact,
in the real world we seek will
see people make offers to and fro.
What's different about the
real world than this model?
All right, let's talk about it. A bet.
How many of you have a,
you must have all bargain for something
in the real world and none of you
probably bargained for a house yet,
but you want a bargain for cars,
I think right in the, in the real world
you make offers go to and fro, right?
What's going on? Why are we getting
off frigging offers in the real world?
Whereas we don't in this game, what
are we missing? Yeah, that's good.
Let's trap it.
Okay.
Uh,
in the real world,
you don't actually know what the other
person discount factor is there for.
You have uncertainty as to what your
highest possible offer can be. Good. Good.
So in the real world,
unlike the model on the board,
not only are those
discount factors different,
but you probably don't know how patient
or in patient, the other side is.
You can get some ideas about
how patients are patient.
The other side is by looking at
other characteristics. For example,
for as long as you know that the person
you're bargaining with over their car,
you're trying to buy that car and they're
a graduate student who's just got a
job in a Adam,
it was Pakistan or something and they
ain't gonna take him to the car with them
and they're leaving next week, you know,
you know they're in a hurry. All right?
So there's times when you're gonna
know something about what other people
discount factor is how patient they are,
but lots of times you're not
going to know. All right?
So one thing is you just don't know
what the discount factor is. By the way,
what else might you not know about the
other side? What else might you not know?
Yeah, how big the surpluses
that you're splitting.
Good. You might not know this good that
you're selling. You might not know.
We've been talking
about the being one pie,
which you're carving up and everyone
knows the size of the Pie, right?
But in the real world, I might
not know that this, this, this,
this object that's being sold.
I might not know how much this object
is worth to the other side and he or she
may not know how much it's
worth to me. Alright, so that,
that lack of information,
lack of information is going to change
the game considerably. In particular,
I might want to turn down some offers
in this game in order to appear like a
patient person.
Well,
I might want to turn down some offers
in the game in order to appear like
somebody who doesn't really value
this all very much. All right.
And in so doing,
I'm going to try and get you to make
me a better offer all answering what's
going on in handling and boggling
bargaining according to this model.
What's missing in this model is the idea
that you don't know who it is you're
bargaining with. You don't know how much
they value the objects and question.
You don't know how impatient they are
to get away with the cash. All right?
So it's a big assumption here. Very big
assumption is that everything is known,
right? So both the Dick
both disc, both patients,
yeah.
Things, uh, both the size of the
pie. What is the value of the pie?
Okay.
The value of the pie
and the value of time
is assumed to be known,
okay.
But in the real world,
you typically don't know the value
of the pie of the other side.
And you typically don't know how
much they value your time. All right?
So that produces a whole
literature on bargaining,
none of which we really have
time to do in this class.
It's a pity because boggling,
ton of important. So instead,
I want to spend the last five
minutes just introducing, uh,
why is it really worth interesting in your
topic in the last five minutes? Um, no,
I don't think it is.
Let me talk a little bit more
about marketing rather than that.
Okay?
All right. So what does
this suggest? All right,
what does this suggest if we're going
out in the real world? All right.
I'll actually take Mr. Taking
this to reality, right?
So one thing it suggests is
people for whom it's noon,
that they're going to be impatient.
People for whom it's known that they
desperately need this deal to go through
are going to do less well in bargains.
Right.
We already knew people made it less
one bonding cause cause they're less
sophisticated players. But here he
doesn't put that as sophisticated.
They can be sophisticated you like, but
they're just going to be in a, in a hurry.
All right. We already talked about the
greatest student who's meeting for us,
Pakistan, right? But who else typically
in bargaining is going to need,
need cash now,
who else is going to be a weaker position
when that bargaining socially and in,
in our society,
I'm trying to get this questions out
here. Yeah. And Labor management, uh,
disputes labor. So that's a good
question. Right? It's a good question.
In Labor management dispute, there's
one going on right now in Hollywood.
It's not clear that right.
Could be. It could be the,
it could be the management side who's
in a hurry because they just need right
now to get a in, um, David Alman,
David David Edmunds stripped
written or that would,
that would tend to favor labor,
but it could be the labor side.
Why might it be the Labor
side? So it never know this,
there's this, there's this,
there's a writer's strike going on
in Hollywood right now. All right?
So the people on the management side
who are in the weakest position or the
people who are in the most
hardy to get this result,
and those are guys with the fewest scripts
in the pipeline and that tends to be
late night TV shows.
So those guys really want this
thing settled fast there in a week.
Bargaining position.
On the other hand,
the maybe a reason why Labor's
in a week bargaining position.
Why might labor being a week bargaining
position relative to management
rents to pay,
right?
They have rents to pay that they have
immediate demands on that cash right to
the typical worker is typically poorer
than your typical manager. Not always,
but typically. All right. Are they just
have to, they have to pay the rent.
They have to feed. They have to
feed that children. All right,
so there's a more general idea
that more generally in bargaining,
the people who are poorer,
typically we'll have this,
isn't this poor in terms of income,
it's poor in terms of
wealth are going to have,
I've got to be more impatient to get
things resolved and that's going to put
them in a weaker bargaining position.
I got a second one.
So in bilateral bargaining,
right,
having low wealth and being known to
have low wealth puts you in a weaker
position and that means that
typically people who are poorer,
I'm going to do less. Well though the
late night TV show, maybe an exception.
All right.
What makes you think a
little bit about weather?
Just setting up a bargaining position
makes things equal for everybody.
All right. Any other thoughts
about who has strengthened,
who has weakness and body?
What are the,
what are the kinds of stumps do
we see people do in bargaining?
What else? He's got a missing
here that we need to think about,
particularly if we want
to do in this class.
It's developed these ideas and
take them to the real world.
So one of the real world, real world
things here are kind of missing.
Yeah.
Usually people make their first offer
a lot higher than what they're actually
willing to accept, right? So
typically, typically you're right,
typically people come,
the typically bargaining isn't
just a series of random numbers.
Typically people start out high and
then they can see towards the middle.
Is that right? So if,
if I, if I'm the buyer,
I start out with a low price and come up.
And if you're the seller,
you start off with a high price
and come down. All right. So again,
that seems to be about
establishing reputation and
trying to indicate how much I
want this. Good. All right. There's,
uh, something worth staying here,
which we haven't got time to doing this
class and I hope you'll have time to
take you to take the foot off plus one 56.
We can actually show formally,
but in a setting in which buyers and
sellers are bargaining and buyers and
sellers do not know how much the good is
worth to the buyer or how much it cost
to the silo. Typically you can
not expect to get efficiency.
Let me say that again.
All right?
So it's kind of an important
economic facts that were,
that's missing from one 15 and
unfortunately missing from this class.
But if we go to a more real world setting
in which people's values and not known,
not only are the offers
not accepted immediately,
and not only is there something near
Quincy in that the port and that be more
impatient than that dude as well.
But also you get,
you get bad inefficiency and
the inefficiency is occurs
essentially because the
sellers want to seem
like that hard and the,
and the buyers want to seem like
that hard and you get a failure,
you get a failed effort for
deals to be made. All right?
So some deals are actually going to
be lost or take a long time in coming.
You're gonna get some strikes before the
deals occur. And that's all inefficient.
Alright,
so bargaining not in this model,
but in the real world tends to
lead to inefficiency. Alright,
so I'll leave it there.
We'll have an earliest lumps were all
starving because the top change anyway.